COLT MCANLIS: So
here's a common problem
that I'm sure you've run into.
It's time to load a
bitmap into memory
for your app, social
media stream or whatever,
but you're out of memory.
You can't load in the
new bitmap without first
destroying one of
the existing bitmaps
you've already got loaded.
But which one do you get rid of?
My name is Colt McAnlis, and the
answer to this tricky question
is actually an entire
field of computer science
that's almost 60 years old,
cache replacement algorithms.
In general, you can
think of the bitmaps
that you have loaded
into memory as a cache.
That is, rather than loading
a given bitmap from disk
each time you want to use it,
you load it into memory once
and then use it over and
over again as it's needed.
This basically means that
a cache stores objects that
might be used in the future.
However, as the cache
starts to fill up,
you eventually need to get
rid of one of the items
in order to make room
for incoming data.
So which one do you get rid of?
Well, since a cache
hold objects that
might be used in the
future, the obvious answer
is to evict one of the objects
that's not needed anymore;
or at worst, wouldn't be used
for the longest period of time.
But it's generally
impossible to predict
how far in the
future information
will be needed again,
even when you've
got awesome algorithms
like this hanging around
in your code base.
Good news is that there's
a simpler way to do this,
and Android has already done
the heavy lifting for you.
The LRU cache class
maintains a list of items
that you place into it.
As an object is accessed, it's
moved to the front of the list
where it will remain until
some other item gets accessed,
and then that gets moved
to the front instead.
When the cache fills
up and it's time
to choose which element
to evict to make room
for the incoming objects,
the decision here is easy.
Objects that are
accessed more frequently
will reside in towards
the front of the list,
while less used objects
will hang towards the back.
This replacement algorithm is
called LRU, or least recently
used, basically saying that
the more an object is used now,
the higher chances are that
it'll be used in the future,
and it should stay
in the cache, which
is perfect for your
social media application.
Now chances are that
if a thumbnail hasn't
been seen in awhile,
then it's probably
been scrolled
offscreen and doesn't
need to be in memory anymore.
Now the LRU cache isn't
a typical container,
and as such requires a bit of
finesse to get working right.
Firstly, the LRU cache manages
elements in a key value
relationship.
When you declare
the object, you need
to figure out what's the
use for key, and what data
you're going to be
storing as a value.
For a cache of
bitmaps, this may be
as simple as using a
filename and a bitmap object.
Secondly, LRU cache
is, by definition,
a bounded container.
It's intended to have a
maximum amount of size,
so that you don't end up
running off into crazy town,
and destroying your
application's memory, which
means during
initialization you need
to define the size
of your cache.
But be careful here.
Making your cache
too small means
you'll get a lot of
evictions, and end up
with a lot of unneeded
bitmap reloads.
Too large of a cache,
on the other hand,
exposes you to potential
out of memory errors
all over the place.
As such, the best practice
means setting your cache size
based upon the amount of memory
available to your application.
Now to find this, you can call
the getMemoryClass function,
which indicates how
hard of a memory limit
your app should impose
on itself in order
to let the system work best.
So grab that number and
then do some division
by 8 or something,
as a starting value.
Over time, you can
tweak this number
based upon what your application
needs, or better yet,
what device you're running
on and its limitations.
Now the next important
part is that we
have to let the cache know
the size of the objects
that it contains, so it knows
how much of its bounded space
is being taken up per object.
To do this, we can
simply extend the class
with our own container,
override the size of method
to return the size of a
given bitmap in bytes.
Now getting objects
from the cache
and putting objects
back into the cache
are pretty straightforward.
I mean the whole thing works
basically like a hash table.
But note that the get function
is actually very helpful here.
If you request an object
that's not in the cache,
or it's been evicted and
doesn't reside there anymore,
then you'll get a
null object return,
which is a great signal.
It means that you should do the
extra work to load the bitmap
and put it in the cache.
But don't worry.
LRU cache will handle all
of the eviction and memory
reclamation for you.
But it's worth pointing
out that any time you
insert a new object
into the cache,
that some of the
existing objects
may be evicted in order
to make space for it.
It's also important to note that
if your cache objects aren't
uniform in size, then
LRU cache could end up
evicting multiple objects
in order to make space
for the larger new one.
So, see?
There you go.
Memory management made easy.
But trust me here.
There's plenty more to be
done to make your application
faster, which is why
you need to check out
the rest of the Android
performance pattern content.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community as well,
to ask others how they've
solved similar problems.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
PERFMATTERS.